[Musique] le
départ de james est né ici à
pravernotook sur les rives de la
baie d'hudson
c'est un chasseur un éducateur un expert en
plein air
il travaille pour un programme local qui emmène les
délinquants sur la terre james et d'
autres leur apprennent à chasser le poisson ou à construire
une
cabane  les aide à renouer avec leurs racines
et les éloigne des limites
de l'incarcération dans le sud
c'est l'un des rares projets dans le
nord du québec qui offre une
alternative au système de justice
pénale dans
lequel la surreprésentation dans le
système judiciaire a atteint des niveaux critiques au
nunavik
l'intérieur  sont incarcérés à un taux
six fois plus élevé que les autres
groupes autochtones au québec
le système de justice a du mal à suivre le
rythme,
voire partisan, en
raison de l'isolement de la région et du
manque d'infrastructures les délinquants ainsi
que leurs victimes n'ont pas droit à
certains des mêmes droits légaux  comme d'autres
québecois les inuits veulent reprendre le
contrôle de leur système de justice on est
comme n'importe qui d'autre qui veut  avoir
leur propre contrôle et ne pas être dirigé par
quelqu'un d'autre
deux visions de la justice l'une du
sud l'autre du nord sont à un
tournant
[Musique]
george hawkeye est un résident de kujak il
participe depuis longtemps à des courses de motoneige et de traîneau à chiens
chasseur de temps il partage ses
prises avec la communauté
[Musique]
il a découvert le système judiciaire en
tant qu'officier de police il y a environ 15 ans
j'ai grandi dans un
quartier pauvre ou une famille pauvre
dans la pauvreté c'est l'une des principales
raisons pour lesquelles je voulais  devenir des
policiers juste pour aider les personnes dans le besoin
après trois ans avec la force qu'il a
rendu son badge
puis en 2011 les choses craignaient bien sûr
quand il en est venu aux coups avec un ancien
collègue
savez-vous d'où venait cette rage
je pense que c'était tout le  facteurs de stress dans ma
vie
mon enfance la police le stress
de la police j'ai fini par blesser un
policier assez gravement
et je voulais me suicider
george s'est retrouvé du mauvais côté de la
loi et a fait face aux nombreuses embûches  des blocages
du système judiciaire au Nunavik, à
commencer par des retards dans les comparutions devant le tribunal
,
il n'y avait personne pour s'occuper de mon cas,
alors j'ai dû m'asseoir en prison, attendre
un avocat, attendre que le système judiciaire
entre en jeu ou tout le monde était en
week-end de congé
.  vient de rester en prison
mangé des ailes de poulet et des frites tout le week-
end sortir de la nourriture
qui a été livrée froide et détrempée
plusieurs avocats de la défense nous ont dit que les
retards pour obtenir une première audience
dépassent toujours régulièrement la limite de trois jours
requise par le code pénal et cela
malgré l'introduction  en 2020 de
vidéoconférence pendant la pandémie
le système a été créé par des
blancs des
gens du sud donc ce n'est
pas fait pour init les
gens ne savent même pas comment contacter un
avocat quand c'est leur première fois
il n'y a pas de centre de détention permanent
au nunavik
le  les accusés en attente de procès doivent être
transportés par avion à saint-jerome dans les
laurentides ou à amos dans la région de btb à des
milliers de kilomètres de chez
nous, nous avons donc dû prendre  e un vol de deux heures
jusqu'à montréal
et à montréal nous avons dû attendre la
camionnette qui allait nous transférer à la
prison un siège dur inconfortable
enfermé dans une petite camionnette
et conduit six sept
heures jusqu'à amos de montréal tous
les retards
le temps que j'ai dû subir en prison
[Musique
] afin de tenir des procès le
système judiciaire lui-même se déplace dans neuf des 14
communautés du nunavut avec ce qu'on appelle
la cour de
circuit la cour de circuit a été mise en place dans
les années 70 dans la foulée  de la
crise de la baie james avec l'intention de rendre
justice aux communautés nordiques,
mais elle a longtemps été étiquetée de l'
étiquette peu flatteuse de cour de cirque
[Musique]
jean-pierre laro a passé près de 40 ans à faire la
police dans la grande région de montréal
avant d'être recruté en 2018 par  le
service de police du nunavik il est
chef de police et directeur de la sécurité publique du nunavut
[musique]
sur une population de 9 000 adultes 1400
personnes en moyenne sont accusées d'au
moins une infraction criminelle  chaque année, la
plupart des cas découlent de
problèmes sociaux tels que le manque de logement ou
la toxicomanie,
ce taux est 20 fois supérieur à la
moyenne provinciale.
musique]
le temps arctique peut être imprévisible des
rafales de vent ont empêché deux vols
transportant l'accusé et des témoins
de décoller d'un autre village des
dizaines de dossiers devaient être
reportés comme d'habitude au nunavik
le juge qui présidait le
tribunal ici pour la première fois l'a
exprimée  consternation devant tous les retards
étrangers
ce détenu vient d'arriver au
palais de justice de kudrai de saint jerome 24
heures plus tard que prévu les
autorités avaient initialement préparé le
mauvais détenu pour le voyage
ils se sont précipités pour envoyer la bonne personne à
cujuac et l'ont fait voyager pendant plus de 18
heures
lea febrero est son avocat
malgré tout sa cause n'a jamais été
entendue le juge n'est pas un habitué de t  le
tribunal de circuit et elle a décidé de ne pas
commencer un procès qu'elle ne pourrait pas
terminer
[Musique]
cette affaire a dû être reportée de
plusieurs mois jusqu'à ce que le tribunal de circuit
revienne dans la région avec un autre juge
jusque-là cet homme devra être envoyé
sud retour au centre de détention de saint jerome
nous devrions l'
étranger
george a passé 20 jours en détention avant de
pouvoir obtenir son enquête
sur le cautionnement lors du procès l'avocat qu'il a engagé à ses
propres frais a réussi à le faire condamner
à l'assignation à résidence
george a pu éviter d'être exilé  dans
une prison du sud,
quel aurait été l'impact de
vous perdre, vous et la communauté, de perdre
quelqu'un comme vous pendant un an, par exemple,
cela a été un grand impact de me perdre pendant
20 jours, je suis sûr que
j'ai fourni aux familles
qui partaient à la chasse j'ai partagé mon  attrape tout
le temps
j'étais également impliqué dans le comité jeunesse
juste pour aider la communauté en
général
les peines intermittentes qui sont purgées
les fins de semaine sont systématiquement prononcées par les
tribunaux du québec mais pas dans  nunevick
[Musique]
efficace
pavernatook abrite 1800 personnes il
a l'un des taux de suicide
et de violence conjugale les plus élevés au québec
il ne manque pas de détenus dans ces
cellules de détention les détenus ont été transportés par avion
de ams pour un tribunal  comparution ont lieu
ici avec des personnes qui ont été
récemment arrêtées
ces cellules sont connues pour contenir
jusqu'à six ou sept personnes à la
fois afin de réduire le nombre d'arrestations
pour des questions telles que les conflits familiaux la
police et le conseil régional de  la santé
s'est associée en 2019 pour créer une
équipe d'intervention mobile cinq soirs par semaine un
policier et un travailleur social
s'associent pour intervenir au besoin dans la
communauté
de leurs
appels les plus récents,
leur objectif est simplement de calmer les choses
, de désamorcer les conflits et de diriger les
personnes en crise vers d'autres
services de santé au lieu du poste de police.
l'ancienne chef du
service de police de nunevic elle travaille maintenant
pour la régie régionale de la santé elle a
créé le programme
ils peuvent emmener une personne à l'hôpital
ils peuvent emmener une personne dans une autre maison
il peut juste être là pour aider à parler avec
la personne
mais ça  Le programme a contribué à réduire le
nombre de personnes finissant en
détention, ils contribuent donc en fait à améliorer de
nombreuses relations au sein de la
communauté
malgré les efforts de recrutement de
personnel inwit, la plupart des policiers
viennent du sud
et les relations avec la population locale
ont tendance à être  tendue
[musique]
a beaucoup à dire sur la justice au nunavik
elle est membre d'une des familles les plus célèbres
de la région
sa tante mary mae simon est
gouverneure
générale du canada c'était un honneur de savoir qu'enoch
et ma tante ont été nommés
cinq ans  il y a jeannie a été mêlée à
une dispute domestique et a contacté
la police
j'ai appelé la police à l'aide
et à son tour
j'ai été violemment arrêtée, ce qui m'a traumatisée
tr
Je pense que le système judiciaire prend beaucoup trop de
temps ici pour résoudre les problèmes
. J'ai connu des personnes qui quittent littéralement le
pujo juste pour avoir cet espace
de leur agresseur si les choses pouvaient être
résolues en temps opportun, alors nous
pourrions faire avancer la victime  l'agresseur
quiconque
nous en avons besoin nous avons besoin de cette résolution
pour pouvoir aller de l'avant
pour les procureurs dont le rôle est de soutenir les
victimes et de traduire les auteurs en
justice la lourde charge de travail peut sembler
intimidante
contacter
le taux de roulement parmi les 20
procureurs impairs travaillant au nunavik est élevé
le  amos office qui offre des
services juridiques dans le nord du québec
a vu partir 14 avocats depuis
avait sa propre façon de traiter avec les gens
qui
créaient des problèmes dans les communautés
[Musique]
les corporations makavic représentent les
inuit dans leurs démarches avec les
gouvernements du canada et du québec
il a signé  un protocole avec le québec
afin de mettre sur pied des comités de
justice des comités de justice aident les contrevenants à s'y retrouver
traiter et offrir
des peines alternatives basées sur des
valeurs culturelles telles que la justice réparatrice et l'
harmonie communautaire
cette vidéo d'un comité de justice nous a été
fournie par le ministère de la justice mackevick
ils peuvent rencontrer la personne qui a
été accusée pour essayer d'aider cette
personne et de comprendre
ses droits et en même temps en
utilisant notre culture comment nous l'avons fait dans le
passé
les personnes à qui nous avons parlé disent que les
ressources et les mesures de prévention
manquent cruellement
dans un rapport spécial tableau en 2016 l'
ombudsman du québec a noté que les peines ne
dissuadent pas les gens  aux prises avec la
toxicomanie
et que les solutions aux problèmes sociaux ne
doivent pas dépendre uniquement du
système judiciaire au lieu d'être
renvoyées pour conduite en état d'ébriété comme si cela se
reproduisait trop souvent si nous nous en occupons
dans notre communauté et parlons avec les
gens peut-être que nous pouvons trouver des solutions
au lieu de les envoyer hors de la
région,
mais moins de deux pour cent des dossiers sont
transférés aux comités de justice a  nd
ils sont principalement pour des infractions mineures telles
que des méfaits ou des vols
[Musique]
la grande majorité des crimes, la violation des
conditions, la conduite avec facultés affaiblies et les
conflits familiaux sont traités par les
protocoles des tribunaux pénaux
voir
étranger
[Musique]
le sens du mot sayoc est un
changement dans  la direction du vent
c'est le nom donné à un programme qui
tout comme les comités de justice offre une
alternative au système judiciaire
le but est de réhabiliter les contrevenants
par des pratiques traditionnelles sur le
terrain
ces éducateurs reviennent d'une
chasse au morse sur la baie d'hudson
leur client l'homme  qui a attrapé le
morse a eu des démêlés avec la loi
ils fourrent de la viande dans des poches de
graisse qui fermenteront pendant deux mois
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient prêtes à être partagées lors d'un
festin communautaire nous allons camper
chasser pêcher
pour qu'ils puissent éviter les ennuis en ville
nous les emmenons sur le terrain où
il n'y a pas de problème
donc
c'est une grande amélioration pour le client nous sommes
allés aux îles d'ottawa à environ 160
kilomètres fr  om ici ils sont à l'aise
pour parler
leur propre langue
ils peuvent nous parler de leurs problèmes
ce programme est considéré comme un succès et
il s'étend lentement à d'autres
communautés
il peut aider en ce sens qu'il donne aux gens
autre chose à faire il leur donne une
activité si  tu pars à la chasse toute une
journée tu vas être épuisé à la
fin de la journée à la fin de la journée si
tu reviens avec ta prise ça
te donne un sentiment de fierté car tu
vas partager non seulement  avec votre
famille, mais avec la communauté,
cela fonctionne parce que nous avons des clients
qui ne sont pas retournés dans le
système judiciaire, ce qui montre que cela fonctionne
makovic qui supervise de nombreux
programmes de justice alternative
aimerait voir les comités traiter un plus grand
nombre d'infractions et recevoir  un
financement supplémentaire auquel
le système doit s'adapter à la région
mettre une
infrastructure appropriée dans la région avoir des gens
dans les communautés qui peuvent s'occuper d'
eux au lieu d'avoir des tribunaux itinérants qui se
rendent dans t  es communautés c'est pourquoi
je dis que nous devrions avoir notre propre
système en place que nous pouvons admettre
administrer nous-mêmes
peu de temps après notre voyage à nunevic
le ministre de la justice du québec simon barrett a
annoncé qu'il avait commandé un
rapport sur la situation en collaboration
avec makovic
étranger
george hawkeye est reconnaissant d'avoir
pu purger sa peine à la maison
et d'avoir obtenu la permission du tribunal de
s'occuper de ses chiens
je dois aller les nourrir de temps
en temps
donc j'ai une heure
pour faire ça tous les jours
et
juste cette heure  de liberté allant à
mes chiens quand j'étais en résidence surveillée
m'a tellement aidé
voici toute la communauté juste en
face des marines cet ancien
policier travaille maintenant à la mise en place d'une
nouvelle organisation qui se battra pour
protéger les droits intérieurs en termes d'accès
à l'éducation aux services de santé
et à la justice,
il y a tellement de choses que nous ne pouvons pas faire à
cause d'un casier judiciaire ici
et nous sommes une petite communauté qui essaie de
prospérer.  je voulais me présenter dans la politique locale pour
aider la communauté
et essayer de faire des
choses
ou essayer d'améliorer les choses au sein de la
communauté et le casier judiciaire
m'a juste empêché de le faire et je
voulais travailler dans différents domaines et le casier
judiciaire m'a juste arrêté tu sais
cette
imposition d'un système à une culture, nous
pouvons évidemment voir que cela ne fonctionne
pas, nous devons donc nous donner plus de
responsabilités, plus de pouvoir sur nous-mêmes
pour pouvoir résoudre ces problèmes
plutôt que de tomber dans les mailles
du système que ce n'est même pas
partie de notre culture